rejoignez-moi sur patronne pour accéder
à l'ensemble de mon contenu inédit des
épisodes spéciaux des cours en visio des
apérophilos un moyen simple de soutenir
mon travail tout en vous donnant matière
à penser je vous attends sur pas créole
le lien est dans la description
bonjour à tous
aujourd'hui on va parler du pari de
Pascal
Pascal est un philosophe et
mathématicien français du XVIIe siècle
on lui doit l'invention de la première
machine à calculer la Pascaline ainsi
que du premier omnibus le carrosse à
cinq sol
et l'une des particularités de Pascal
c'est qu'il est un philosophe chrétien
un philosophe qui croit en Dieu
mais qui considère en même temps que
l'existence de Dieu ne peut pas être
démontré
si vous préférez que Dieu est
inatteignable par la raison
alors des philosophes croyants il y en a
eu des tonnes
c'était même l'immense majorité jusqu'au
19e siècle
mais un philosophe croyant qui affirmait
qu'on ne pouvait pas démontrer
l'existence de Dieu
c'est déjà un peu moins courant
le contre-exemple étant des cartes
les cartes qui a lui aussi vécu au 17e
siècle il est né 27 ans avant Pascal
et qui dans ces méditations
métaphysiques a exposé un certain nombre
d'arguments dans le but de prouver
rationnellement l'existence de Dieu
son argument le plus connu c'est ce
qu'on appelle l'argument ontologique
c'est à dire l'idée qu'on pourrait
déduire l'existence de Dieu de sa
définition
Dieu se définit comme un être parfait or
s'il n'existait pas il ne serait pas
parfait donc Dieu existe
cet argument sera réfuté par Emmanuel
Kant au siècle suivant quand qui
montrera que ce qu'a fait des cartes ce
n'est pas prouver l'existence de Dieu
c'est seulement qu'il a placé
l'existence de Dieu dans sa définition
de Dieu
si Dieu est à notre parfait il existe
soit mais à ce compte là un triangle
parfait existe puisqu'il est parfait
l'homme parfait existe puisqu'il est
parfait
ça tient pas
sans compter que pour quand Dieu est
au-delà de nos facultés d'entendement
on peut penser Dieu on peut croire en
l'existence de Dieu mais on ne peut pas
la démontrer
Dieu est au-delà de la raison selon
quand
et bien ça c'est déjà ce que disait
Pascal au 17e siècle à savoir que pour
Pascal Dieu peut être un objet de foi
mais il ne peut pas être un objet de
connaissance
en tout cas pas au sens de connaissance
rationnelle
c'est la distinction que faisait Pascal
entre les vérités de raison et les
vérités de cœur
le cœur a ses raisons que la raison
ignore ça voulait dire il y a des choses
qui ne se prouvent pas mais qui
s'éprouve
on peut connaître Dieu par la révélation
par l'expérience intime de la
transcendance divine
d'ailleurs c'est ce qui est arrivé à
Pascal sa fameuse nuit de feu une nuit
au cours de laquelle Pascal a vécu une
expérience mystique qu'il a aussitôt
retranscrite dans un poème qui s'appelle
le mémorial et dont d'ailleurs il n'a
jamais parlé à personne
mais c'est cette expérience qui a
vraiment fait prendre conscience à
Pascal que la foi était une expérience
trop personnelle trop incommunicable
pour pouvoir faire l'objet d'une
démonstration rationnelle
et ça ces problématiques
parce que comment convertir les
sceptiques comment convertir les athées
ou les agnostiques si on ne peut pas
prouver rationnellement l'existence de
Dieu
les sceptiques ils ne veulent pas des
témoignages
ça ne les convaincra pas un témoignage
ce qu'ils veulent ce sont des raisons
rationnelles de croire
et bien c'est exactement ça l'enjeu du
pari de Pascal
le pari c'est un argument mis au point
par Pascal pour inciter les non-croyants
à croire en Dieu
et qui consiste à dire quand l'absence
de preuve
il est rationnel de croire
pourquoi parce que si vous ne croyez pas
en Dieu et qu'il existe
vous perdez tout
tandis que si vous croyez en Dieu et
qu'il n'existe pas vous ne perdez rien
ce que vous proposons cet épisode c'est
qu'on analyse cet argument
pour voir à la fois en quoi il peut être
convaincant et en quoi il ne l'est pas
et au-delà de nous demander si derrière
cette notion de Paris
il n'y a pas quelque chose qui nous
concerne tous
et qui peut nous aider à comprendre la
nature de la foi
alors déjà commençons par expliciter ce
que veut dire Pascal quand il dit qu'on
a rien à perdre à croire en Dieu mais
qu'on risque de tout perdre si on n'y
croit pas
ce que nous dit Pascal c'est au fond la
position classique défendue par l'Église
catholique
à savoir que si on ne croit pas en Dieu
notre
âme sera d’année
on brûlera en enfer pour l'éternité
tandis que si on croit en Dieu et qu'on
suit ses préceptes
notre âme sera sauvée
nous irons au paradis
mais vous aurez remarqué que j'ai ajouté
et qu'on suit ses préceptes
et oui parce que croire en Dieu sans
appliquer ces préceptes
croiront Dieu sans agir conformément à
sa volonté ça ne suffit pas
il ne suffit donc pas d'avoir la foi
pour aller au paradis
encore faut-il que notre foi se
traduisent dans une pratique
et ça c'est très important
c'est très important pour comprendre le
pari de Pascal mais c'est très important
pour comprendre ce qu'est une religion
à savoir qu'une religion et c'est ça qui
est la différencie d'une spiritualité
une religion c'est le mariage d'une
croyance et d'une pratique
la croyance en l'existence de Dieu et
l'action conforme à la volonté de Dieu
parce qu'après tout on peut très bien
croire en Dieu mais ne pas avoir de
pratique religieuse
on peut très bien penser que Dieu existe
mais se dire que Dieu n'attend rien de
nous
qui n'est pas un juge qu'il n'est pas un
examinateur moral et qui laisse les
mortels que nous sommes
vivraient agir comme il l'entendent
et donc ça évidemment c'est pas
compatible avec la doctrine chrétienne
doctrine chrétienne qui nous dit que le
salut de notre âme passe nécessairement
par l'accomplissement de bonnes œuvres
c'est parce qu'on a
œuvré pour le bien qu'on va au paradis
pas juste parce qu'on a cru
et d'ailleurs d'un point de vue chrétien
même d'un point de vue religieux en
général
croire en Dieu sans obéir au
commandement de Dieu croire en Dieu sans
vouloir accomplir sa volonté ça n'a pas
vraiment de sens
parce qu'alors rien ne distingue le
croyant de l'impie
de la même façon que si on aime
quelqu'un on n'imagine pas qu'on puisse
vouloir lui faire du mal
un croyant sans piété un croyant non
pratiquant ce n'est pas un vrai croyant
du point de vue religieux
il finira en enfer comme tous les
mécréants
au passage je rappelle que mes créons ce
n'était pas une insulte
un mécréant c'est quelqu'un qui met
croit
c'est un athée
donc pourquoi c'est important de
préciser que croire en Dieu ne suffit
pas et bien parce que c'est sur ce point
que ce sont focalisés un certain nombre
de critiques du pari de Pascal
Pascal nous dit si vous croyez vous
serez sauvé
la réalité c'est que pour être sauvé la
croyance doit se prolonger dans l'action
alors il se trouve que Pascal a répondu
à cet objectif
il a répondu que certes la croyance ne
suffisait pas
mais que la croyance était le premier
pas vers l'entrée en religion
et que donc son pari a d'abord vocation
à faire accomplir ce premier pas
commencez par la croyance pour
qu'ensuite cette croyance débouche sur
une pratique religieuse
donc admettons que l'objection soit
levée
admettons que Pascal veuille
effectivement amener les sceptiques à
croire en Dieu comme sort de première
étape vers une vie religieuse
la question est alors de savoir
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire qu'on ne perd
rien à croire en Dieu
parce que si Dieu n'existe pas et que je
passe ma vie à me conformer à des règles
pour satisfaire ce Dieu qui n'existe pas
je perds beaucoup
je perds même énormément
et donc la critique qui a été faite à
Pascal c'est que si ma croyance m'oblige
à avoir un comportement religieux
qu'elle m'oblige à m'a quitter de
certaines actions et qu'elle m'en
interdit d'autre
et qu'à l'arrivée Dieu n'existe pas
dire que je ne perds rien
c'est pas vrai
prenons un exemple
si je crois en Dieu et que Dieu me dit
la fornication c'est mal
si tu t'adonnes à la fornication tu iras
en enfer
d'accord
bah dans ce cas je vais m'abstenir
autrement dit je vais m'empêcher
d'accomplir ce qui d'un point de vue
terrestre constitue un plaisir
parce que d'un point de vue religieux ce
n'est pas un plaisir
c'est un péché
donc il y a bien l'idée d'un sacrifice
un sacrifice en terme de plaisir un
sacrifice en terme de liberté
de liberté au sens de libre satisfaction
de mes désirs
parce que bien sûr tout dépend de la
définition qu'on donne à la liberté
pour un athé libertin la fornication
c'est une liberté
pour un religieux chrétien c'est une
soumission
une soumission à la tentation
à Satan
mais au-delà des mots le fait est que si
ma croyance en Dieu
m'oblige à faire une croix sur les
plaisirs terrestres je ne peux pas dire
que je ne perds rien
d'un point de vue athée les plaisirs
terrestres c'est même la seule chose que
nous ayons
d'un point de vue à thé il n'y a rien
au-delà des plaisirs de la matière
donc si je perds les plaisirs terrestres
je perds tout
le présupposé de Pascal c'est que les
plaisirs terrestres seraient au fond
sans importance
mais ça c'est la perspective d'un
croyant
c'est par rapport au bienfaits de la
croyance que les bienfaits de la non
croyance sont jugés sans valeur
donc finalement est-ce que le pari de
Pascal n'est pas condamné à ne
convaincre que des personnes qui
seraient déjà convaincus
est-ce que le pari de Pascal n'est pas
condamné a renforcé la frontière entre
les religieux qui pensent qu'il faut
sacrifier les plaisirs terrestres au
profit de Dieu
et ceux qui tiennent absolument au
plaisir terrestre parce qu'ils n'en
connaissent pas d'autres
donc là il faut réajuster un peu ce que
nous dit Pascal
en réalité
Pascal exagère lorsqu'il dit qu'on ne
perd rien à croire en Dieu
ce qu'il veut dire c'est que dans la
perspective où Dieu existe bel et bien
les avantages obtenus par le fait d'y
croire sont infiniment supérieurs je dis
bien infiniment supérieur à la perte
occasionnée si on n'y croit pas
parce que si on croit en Dieu et qu'il
n'existe pas
ce qu'on aura perdu ce sont les plaisirs
matériels
tandis que si il existe et qu'on n'y
croit pas
ce qu'on aura perdu
c'est la béatitude éternelle
et inversement nous dit Pascal le
sacrifice de nos plaisirs matériels
n'est rien en comparaison des flammes
éternelles de l'enfer
conclusion il est mathématiquement plus
avantageux de croire en Dieu que de ne
pas y croire
ce que fait Pascal à travers sa
métaphore du Paris c'est ce qu'on
appelle un argument probabiliste
et ça c'est très ingénieux
pourquoi c'est ingénieur
parce que ça consiste à prendre les
athées
sur leur propre terrain
à savoir le terrain de la raison
le terrain des mathématiques et de la
logique
alors
expliquons un peu ça
un athée c'est quelqu'un qui ne croit
pas en Dieu
ah TOS absence de Dieu
philosophiquement les athées sont des
matérialistes
c'est à dire qu'il ne croit pas dans
l'existence d'une réalité
transcendante au monde physique
donc en l'absence d'une preuve
matérielle de l'existence de Dieu il
considère qu'il n'y a aucune raison de
croire
mais les athées sont aussi des
rationalistes
rationalistes non pas au sens de
Descartes
puisque Descartes était un rationaliste
qui pensaient qu'on pouvait démontrer
rationnellement l'existence de Dieu
mais rationalistes au sens où il rejette
la foi et le mysticisme comme principe
d'explication du monde
et bien c'est là dessus que va jouer
Pascal
Pascal va s'adresser au rationaliste
avec un argument
issu de la logique rationaliste
en l'occurrence avec un argument
mathématique
l'argument des probabilités
imaginons
vous jouez à pile ou face
les mathématiques vous disent que vous
avez 50% de chances de tomber sur pile
et 50% de chance de tomber surface
en tant que rationaliste vous savez donc
qu'il n'y a aucune raison de privilégier
l'une des issues par rapport à l'autre
vous pouvez donc vous en remettre
entièrement au hasard
maintenant imaginez que si c'est pile
qui sort
vous gagnez 100 euros
mais que si c'est face qui sort vous
gagnez 1 million d'euros
qu'est-ce que vous allez choisir
ben vous allez choisir face
sans hésiter
parce que dans une situation où vous
n'avez pas plus de chance que ce soit
pile ou que ce soit face ce qui va faire
pencher la balance
c'est ce que vous avez à y gagner
donc d'un point de vue purement
rationaliste
vous allez choisir face
et bien ce que nous dit Pascal c'est que
pour Dieu c'est pareil
Dieu peut exister comme il peut ne pas
exister
mais sauf que dans un cas vous pouvez
gagner 100 euros c'est à dire les
plaisirs terrestres
et dans l'autre cas vous pouvez gagner
un million d'euros c'est à dire le
paradis
donc il n'y a pas hésité
choisir pile étant l'athéisme
ce serait irrationnel
parier sur l'existence de Dieu pour
Pascal c'est ça qui est rationnel
donc c'est en ce sens qu'on peut dire
que Pascal prend les athées sur leur
propre terrain
le terrain de la raison mathématique
le terrain du calcul probabiliste
et c'est en cela que le pari pascalien
n'est pas seulement une image amusante
mais qui constitue un argument
philosophique
car c'est un argument logique et
rationnel
destiné à des esprits qui se veulent
logique et rationnel
alors il y a quand même un problème
on avait dit qu'on allait analyser
l'argument de Pascal et voir en quoi il
était convaincant et en quoi il ne
l'était pas
et là force et d'admettre qu'un problème
se pose
quel est ce problème
ce problème c'est la quantification de
la probabilité de l'existence de Dieu
par rapport à celle de sa non existence
autrement dit c'est le fait de
présupposer que l'existence de Dieu et
la non-existence de Dieu ce serait du
50/50
c'est Pascal lui-même qui prend l'image
du pile ou face
autrement dit du 50/50
mais ce 55 ans en réalité
il ne reflète pas la probabilité de
l'existence de Dieu
il reflète la probabilité de la
métaphore qui l'utilise à savoir le pile
ou face
un athée ne serait pas d'accord avec
cette probabilité
parce que pour un athé la probabilité
que Dieu existe elle tend plutôt vers
zéro
55 ans c'est dans le cas où on aurait
strictement aucun avis
c'est dans le cas où il n'y aurait pas
d'éléments qui ferait pencher la bascule
d'un côté plutôt que de l'autre
or pour un athé
la balance penche clairement
elle penche clairement du côté de la
non-existence
un at ne se dit pas qu'il y a 50 % de
chances que Dieu existe
il ne pense pas
parce qu'il se dit en l'absence de
preuve je n'ai aucune raison de croire
aucune
passe à 30%
. donc la question c'est de savoir
est-ce que ça a du sens de parier sur
l'existence de Dieu en faisant comme
s'il y avait 50% de chances que Dieu
existe et 50% de chance qu'il n'existe
pas
est-ce que c'est raisonnable
et bien pour Pascal oui
c'est raisonnable
c'est raisonnable si on comprend que ce
que Pascal quantifie
ce n'est pas la probabilité que Dieu
existe
c'est la probabilité de savoir que Dieu
on l'a dit tout à l'heure pour Pascal la
raison est incapable de nous renseigner
sur l'existence de Dieu
or la raison c'est ce sur quoi nous
sommes censés fonder nos jugements
mais comme Dieu échappe totalement notre
raison
autrement dit comme notre raison ne nous
est d'aucun secours pour savoir si Dieu
existe ou pas
ça veut dire que rationnellement parlant
il n'y a pas plus de raison d'y croire
qu'il n'y a de raison de ne pas y croire
puisque nous n'en savons rien
tout tient dans ce rien
c'est pas qu'on sait peu c'est pas qu'on
sait partiellement ou imparfaitement
c'est qu'on ne sait pas du tout
et quand on ne sait pas du tout et qu'il
y a deux possibilités de réponse
chacune de ces possibilités
a le même taux de probabilité
c'est très important de comprendre ce
point
dans la vie de tous les jours si vous
pariez sur la réalité d'un événement ou
sur l'existence d'un phénomène
même si vous n'y connaissez pas grand
chose
vous allez essayer de vous raccrocher à
des éléments d'information
vous allez raisonner vous allez
envisager faire des hypothèses
pour essayer de vous faire une idée
vous pouvez vous faire une idée dès lors
que vous avez un certain nombre
d'informations à votre disposition
ce que nous dit Pascal c'est que
s'agissant de Dieu nous n'avons aucune
information
aucune information parce que notre
raison est fondamentalement incapable de
penser Dieu
d'où l'idée que l'existence de Dieu ou
sa non existence
constitue deux issues qui ont la même
probabilité
je rappelle que l'étymologie du mot pari
c'est parrirait qui veut dire rendre
égal
parier en ancien français ça se disait
Perrier
et Périer c'était faire la paire
paire
la paire sous-entendue
50 50
chance égale
pour Pascal
donnait plus de crédit à la
non-existence de Dieu qu'à son existence
c'est ça qui est rationnel
précisément parce qu'envisager Dieu sous
l'angle de la rationalité
envisager Dieu sous l'angle de la preuve
ça n'a aucun sens
on envisage pas sous l'angle de la
preuve quelque chose qui échappe à la
preuve
quelque chose dont la nature même est
d'échapper à la preuve
pourquoi dans la nature même est déjà
pas la preuve
parce que le domaine du divin
estontologiquement séparés du domaine de
la raison humaine
parce que la raison humaine est
plafonnée
et que ce n'est pas par le biais de la
raison qu'on peut entrer en contact avec
Dieu
on entre en contact avec Dieu par le
cœur
c'est à dire par la foi
par une expérience qui transcende toutes
les limites de la rationalité
donc il y a rien à faire
la raison est impuissante
et quand la raison croit réfuter
l'existence de Dieu en s'appuyant sur
ses propres critères d'évaluation
elle ne peut qu’échouer
d'ailleurs petite parenthèse
quand on dit que si on a aucune preuve
on a aucune raison de croire
ça n'a pas de sens
c'est le contraire
c'est quand on a aucune preuve qu'on
croit
justement parce que si on avait des
preuves on ne croirait plus
on saurait
le propre de la croyance c'est qu'elle
est indépendante de la preuve
on croit quand on ne sait pas
pas quand on sait
on croit parce qu'on n'a pas de preuve
donc pour en terminer sur ce point si
parce qu'elle considère qu'il y a autant
de raisons de croire en Dieu qu'il y a
de raison de ne pas y croire
c'est parce que la raison est en
fondamentalement incapable de se
prononcer
nous sommes dans l'inconnu total
la seule chose que nous savons c'est
qu'il existe deux possibilités
deux possibilités entre lesquelles il
est impossible de trancher si ce n'est
que croire en lune et mathématiquement
plus avantageux que croire en l'autre
il faut parier sur l'existence de Dieu
parce que cette option est porteuse
d'une perspective bien plus grande
pour finir je vous propose qu'on
s'arrête un peu sur le choix qui a fait
Pascal de prendre l'image du Paris
c'est quoi un pari
c'est quand on mise sur la vérité d'une
proposition
sans savoir si cette proposition est ou
sera vraie
vous allez voir un match de foot
vous pariez sur votre équipe
si elle gagne vous gagnez
si elle perd vous perdez
alors vous pouvez très bien parier sur
l'équipe que vous n'aimez pas
c'est à dire que vous pouvez croire que
votre équipe va perdre
parce que vous la savez objectivement
moins bonne
mais le fait est que quand vous parliez
vous ne savez pas
c'est un peu le principe
et c'est ce qui fait que les paris
sportifs sont considérés officiellement
comme des jeux de hasard
alors même qu'ils intègrent une part de
connaissances sportives
d'où l'existence des cotes
la cote d'une équipe c'est la
probabilité théorique qu'elle gagne ou
qu'elle perde
si un match de foot est organisé entre
l'équipe du Brésil et l'équipe de
Saint-Marin et que vous pariez sur
Saint-Marin
sachant que dans toute son histoire
Saint-Marin a remporté qu'un seul match
les connaisseurs risquent de vous
regarder bizarrement
mais après tout vous pouvez gagner
on n'en sait rien
on n'en sait rien tant que le coup de
sifflet final n'a pas été donné
et quand on parie sur une équipe dont on
sait qu'elle n'a quasiment aucune chance
de gagner
c'est qu'on a foi en cette équipe
c'est qu'on croit en elle
en dépit de ce qu'on sait sur elle
le pari c'est une métaphore de la foi
quand on parie on croit au double sens
du terme
on croit au sens où on pense
et on croit au sens où on a la foi
au sens où on fait confiance
la foi c'est un mélange de confiance de
volonté et d'espoir
et même si certains diront qu'il
détestent parier parce que parier c'est
misé sur l'inconnu
le fait est comparé tous
on parie dès lors qu'on décide de faire
confiance
quand vous vous mariez vous faites à
Paris
parce que vous décidez de faire
confiance à quelqu'un sans avoir la
preuve que vous avez raison de lui faire
confiance
qu'est-ce que je veux dire par là
je veux dire que par définition
on peut pas savoir ce qui va arriver
on ne peut pas savoir ce que l'autre
fera
donc quand on fait confiance à quelqu'un
on mise sur le fait que ce qu'il fera
sera en conformité avec ce qu'il a fait
jusqu'à présent
donc c'est bel et bien un pari
comme le fait de parier sur le Brésil
plutôt que sur Saint-Marin parce que
jusqu'à présent le Brésil a fait la
preuve de son niveau
on fait confiance à partir de ce qui a
été
et on prolonge ce qui a été dans le
futur pour rationaliser le fait d'avoir
confiance
mais rigoureusement parlant on peut pas
savoir
une surprise est toujours possible
une trahison est toujours possible
plus vous passez du temps avec quelqu'un
plus vous augmentez statistiquement la
possibilité que cette personne vous
trahisse
alors oui c'est un peu démoralisant de
voir les choses comme ça
mais la question n'est pas savoir si
c'est démoralisant
la question est de savoir si c'est vrai
si c'est vrai au-delà de nos convictions
intimes
et au-delà de nos illusions
bah oui c'est vrai
faire confiance c'est prendre le risque
d'être trahi
c'est prendre le risque de se tromper
ces mises
et pourtant
on le fait tous
dès lors qu'on fait confiance à
quelqu'un on parle
et c'est là qu'on en arrive à quelque
chose d'intéressant
confiance et foi ont la même étymologie
fidèles en latin
qui a donné fidèle
le fidèle c'est celui qui est adepte
d'une religion
et être fidèle c'est honorer la foi
qu'on a placé en nous
le fait de faire confiance
comme le fait d'être fidèle à cette
confiance
ce sont des manifestations profanes de
la foi
de ce qu'on pourrait appeler la foi
quotidienne
la foi ordinaire
la foi qui fait qu'on va se marier ou
qu'on va confier un secret
confie et c'est faire confie en
et quand on fait confiance à l'autre ça
veut dire qu'on s'en remet à lui
comme certains sont remettent à Dieu
ce qu'il faut retenir de tout ça c'est
que parier sur l'existence de Dieu
n'est finalement pas plus absurde
pas moins raisonnable
que parier sur notre prochain
la question est de savoir
qu'est-ce qui nous pousse à Paris
qu'est-ce qui nous pousse à faire
confiance
la preuve
non
parce qu'il n'y a pas de preuve de
l'avenir
ce qui nous pousse à faire confiance
c'est la foi
ce mélange de confiance de volonté et
d'espoir
ce qui nous pousse à faire confiance
c'est le fait de vouloir croire
et quand on fait confiance on se
retrouve dans la même situation que
celle que décrit Pascal
soit notre confiance sera honoré
soit notre confiance sera trahi
mais une fois qu'on croit notre croyance
n'est plus divisée
elle est pleine
c'est du
le calcul s'effondre quand notre choix
est fait
je cite
examinons donc ce point et disons Dieu
est ou il n'est pas mais de quel côté
pencherons-nous la raison n'y peut rien
déterminer il y a un chaos infini qui
nous sépare il se joue un jeu à
l'extrémité de sa distance infinie où il
arrivera croire ou pile que gâterez-vous
par raison vous ne pouvez faire ni l'un
ni l'autre par raison vous ne pouvez
défendre nulle des deux ne blâmez donc
pas de fausseté ceux qui ont pris un
choix car vous n'en savez rien non mais
je les blâmerai d'avoir fait non ce
choix mais un choix car encore que celui
qui prend croix et l'autre soit en part
il faute ils sont tous deux en fautes le
juste est de ne point parier oui mais il
faut parier cela n'est pas volontaire
vous êtes embarqué lequel prendrez-vous
donc voyons puisqu'il faut choisir
voyons ce qui vous intéresse le moins
vous avez deux choses à perdre le vrai
et le bien et deux choses à engager
votre raison et votre volonté votre
connaissance et votre béatitude et votre
nature a deux choses à fuir l'erreur et
la misère votre raison n'est pas plus
blessée puisqu'il faut nécessairement
choisir en choisissant l'un que l'autre
voilà un point vidé mais votre béatitude
pesons le gain et la perte en prenant
croix que Dieu est examinons ces deux
cas si vous gagnez vous gagnez tout si
vous perdez vous ne perdez rien gagez
donc qu'il est sans hésiter
le pari de Pascal se veut une
démonstration
qu'il y a des situations où il est
rationnel de croire
où il est rationnel d'avoir la foi
car c'est la seule possibilité
d'envisager un au-delà
or la vie est faite de projection dans
l'au-delà
l'au-delà ce n'est pas seulement le
paradis
ce n'est pas seulement
l'autre monde
c'est aussi
l'au-delà du présent
le futur
le futur qui n'est jamais là
le futur qui n'est pas encore présent
mais dans lequel pourtant
nous plaçons notre foi
dans lequel nous croyons
nous y croyons comme à quelque chose qui
va arriver
et nous y croyons comme à quelque chose
qui soutient nos espoirs
le futur c'est cet horizon qui ne cesse
de reculer
à chaque fois que nous faisons un pas
dans sa direction
le futur
c'est l'inatteignable
c'est l'immetrisable
c'est l'inconnu
et c'est parce qu'on ne peut pas le
connaître
qu'on ne peut que l'espérer
qu'on ne peut que le vouloir
et avoir foi en lui
je vous remercie
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]